you're listening to episode 13 of
storycast 21 i'm james secker
saturday september the 11th 2021 marks
the 20th anniversary of the 9 11 attacks
on the united states which left nearly 3
000 dead and injured some 25 000 people
shortly after 8 o'clock that morning a
group of islamic terrorists hijacked
four airplanes before flying them
towards landmark buildings in new york
and washington dc
in the hours that followed the deadliest
attack on u.s soil since pearl harbor
unfolded live on tv screens around the
world
but as we struggle to make sense of what
we were watching
hundreds of survivors remained trapped
in the upper floors of the world trade
center in new york
the episode you're about to hear is a
graphic first person account from inside
to world trade center
all that we couldn't see in those
minutes
told by someone he was just beneath the
impact zone when the second plane hit
this is 911 janice brooks
inside the south tower
[Music]
my name is janice brooks
i'm originally from london from the east
end of london
i worked for a company of money brokers
called euro brokers and we had an office
in london
i answered the telephone i worked for
the managing director i worked for the
brokers if they needed cabs if they
needed flowers i did invoices i did
typings that was kind of a multifaceted
role
the ceo of the company
whose name was gil
he always said to me come and work for
me in new york come and work for me in
new york
and it was one of those okay
what am i doing with my life kind of
moments
i'd been married
not for me
and i just felt that
i love america
it took a little while but um i finally
made the decision to uh go to work in
new york
and i moved on august 23 2001.
i couldn't believe that not only was i
working there but i was working in the
world trade center
head office was on the 84th floor of two
world trade center which was the south
tower
so we're in for another very nice day
very warm day across the tri-state
september 11th was the most glorious day
we've got clear skies 56 degrees in new
york city i left for work about 7 20.
living in battery park was literally a
10 minute walk from my apartment to the
office
and i was at my desk by about
7 30.
gill who
is the ceo of the company and keith who
was a cfo were in london
so i knew that i wanted to get into the
office early so that i could talk to
them to give them final figures from the
day before
so i remember picking up the telephone
to call london
and then i heard a loud bang
and my pc screen flickered
now some very very sketchy details
reaching us here at sky center important
enough to bring to you though at this
early stage we believe that a plane has
crashed into the world trade center in
new york that happened within the last
few moments no details at this stage i
could see
through the window
paper swirling around we are hearing
reports of a 737 not yet confirmed i ran
around the corner to see brian to ask
him what happened let's have a look what
cbs news is saying our colleagues he
said it was probably some kind of
construction explosion we understand
that a plane so i went back to my desk
you know just really just carried on
with work
there was just a loud shout
everybody out a man's voice shouting
everybody out
attention 68 engine 35 engines 50 engine
64 engine 94
so i picked up the phone
i was put through to robin the head of
the london office
but i said just to let you know
something's happening next door i don't
know what's going on but i'm getting
ready to leave the plane obviously went
in
on one side and came out the other
there's he then screaming down the phone
to me something's happening next door in
hell janice a plane's gone into the
building get the [ __ ] out of there
screaming like
down the telephone to me clouds and
smoke billowing from the top of that
building 110 stories high i grabbed my
bag
started running around from my desk
let's listen to our colleagues in new
york i saw three guys coming towards me
brian dan and dominic
smiling we don't know if it was a
private aircraft and just saying it's
okay it's next door we should be okay
what do you want to do
i carried on running
and as i ran into the corridor steve and
jose
who were the fire wardens for the
company
were kind of motioning people into the
stairwell
it was a tuesday no one seemed to have
any any fear about what was happening
people were in the corridor talking
about what had happened over the weekend
you know plans they had for that week
it wasn't an anxious situation it may
have been simply a suicidal pilot who
wanted to make a problem so we're
walking down
um
there was an announcement through the
intercom system a man's voice
please can everyone stand still
a complete block of the entire plaza we
are being asked not to evacuate to world
trade center because of the incident at
one world trade center the space on the
plaza is currently being used as a
triage center
go to your nearest re-entry point and
return to your office
no one had a problem with that our
re-entry point was two floors underneath
which was the 72nd floor building 193rd
floor southwest corner
by the time i got to the lift there was
a quite a gang of people there
and someone said you know what we might
as well walk back up a plane has hit the
side of one of the twin towers at the
world trade center in new york it
happened on a clear
day people were still walking down
and
one girl said to me where you going and
we said well we're heading back up to
our office oh no she said we're still
heading out and the majority of the
people were heading down still so we
waited for there to be a little people
coming down and started walking on the
way up
many hundreds of people will already
have been inside that building it's just
on the tip of the financial district of
new york the very tip of manhattan
we believe that it's affected something
like 10 stories eyewitnesses say they
saw a fireball we were walking for
probably
10 minutes maybe
then
at a certain point you come out of the
stairwell
and go into a connecting corridor and
then you come out the other side and go
back into the stairwell
i was probably at the back of
a gang of about 10 people
i
had taken a couple of steps into the
corridor
and there was this loud crashing sound
there's another explosion
another plane we just saw a plane flying
by waiting for it to come out of the
other side of that building
and it did everything fell from the
ceiling light switches were falling down
cables were falling down dust and
and pieces of
ceiling were all over the place
i was knocked to the side i didn't fall
down but you know i was jostled to the
side we just saw on live television as a
second plane
flew into
the second tower of the world trade
center now after about probably a couple
of minutes
the dust settled
we everyone standing up and dusting
themselves off
we turned around and went to go out the
door we just came through
when we opened the door
the staircase had gone
and all we could see were
kind of like
dust darkness
and
some flickering of flames
[Music]
then there was this almighty screaming
sound a woman screaming at
the scream of nightmares a scream that i
can still hear in my head
and then bashing on the door at the top
we were meant to go through
bashing on the door
this seems to be around 100 stories up
affecting many many people affecting
those presumably further down as well
the door was open
a lady came through first
she had glass in her hair she had glass
all over her
someone had taken off a t-shirt
wrapped it around her arm
she also had
looked to me like the majority of her
toes on one foot was missing the
eyewitnesses have been saying that they
just saw a flash another guy came out
with
shards of glass in his chest that people
were pulling out
and then finally came the screaming lady
she hadn't stopped screaming all this
time
i can't see i can't see i can't see and
both of her eyes were full of blood
someone had a bottle of water they
washed
washed out her eyes she took her hair
and glass just went everywhere
we actually assumed
[Music]
that the building next door was
collapsing into us
all the people that come through said
that they were walking back into the
corridor and there was a loud whistling
sound and they looked up
and
the glass on that side of the building
just collapsed into them and that's why
they were covered in blood and they ran
back
to come through the door
[Music]
on the first floor we can't
go
down
the staircase we just came from because
it's not there anymore
and then as if by magic there was
another door
and one by one
we all squeezed through
and six trucks and three battalions
responding for various staging points
are you ready to write the identities i
just remember there being dust and my
feet being sticky there were
for some strange reason
bottles of coke little tiny bottles of
coke and pepsi
that had
kind of just exploded and then were all
down the floor there was some water
dripping down there was a pipe with
water on going all down the floor
all right you're gonna get engine two
five eight
two five nine
three two five the guy that i was with
said okay guys we have to get out of
here come on we need to start moving
so
one by one you know we joined it
a trailer started going down
let me remind colleagues who were just
joining us that um just a couple of
minutes ago i was telling viewers that a
plane had collided with one of the twin
towers in new york
as i was explaining what had happened we
saw the silhouette of another plane
in the sky as we were talking and then
this happened you know we're now on i
i'm thinking about the
72nd floor and it's two staircases for
each floor so we have a long way to go
to go down came straight through that
building the guy from eurobrokers kept
running up and down come on guys let's
move come on let's keep moving let's
keep going let's keep going
that's fine
acting we're a couple blocks away you
want to get the box
after walking for about i think 20 20
minutes um some firemen were coming up
the stairs
kind of like looked over us
to see that we were at least making our
way down and no one needed help and they
carried on upstairs
i remember looking down at my shirt
and there was blood all over my shirt
and i could feel this scream building
inside
and i just stopped
the guy from your brokers him running
back up and said you know what what's
happened and i remember
holding my shirt away from my body and
said look i've got blood on my shirt
i've got blood on my shirt
and he said look it's okay it's not your
shirt
we have to get out of here
[Music]
and i looked up at him and i started to
cry and said i don't even know your name
and his name was bob
[Music]
i kind of gathered myself together
and just
kind of
kept walking to be honest
the lady in front with a bad leg and the
bad arm it started to shake
the lady behind had to keep stopping to
you know with her asthma she had she had
a pump
so we were we were the slow end of of
the the queue of people for sure
new pictures just coming in we're
looking up from ground level up towards
the top of the twin towers of the world
trade center on the southern end of
manhattan island in the heart of new
york city so you can see smoke and
flames rising from the
huge gash in both buildings caused by
the passenger jets
that we now kept going we kept going we
kept going we're kind of like i'm
getting a sense of we're near the bottom
the lady in front just stopped stead and
said i said i can't go anymore she was
shaking there was blood dripping from
her front from her feet there was blood
dripping from her elbow she turned this
white color i can't i can't do it i'm
okay i'm gonna sit here you guys go and
you send someone up to help me
bob's like no come on we have to go we
have to keep going
she kept going a bit more and then
finally she just sat down and said i
can't do it anymore
and what did he do
he picked her up
and it gave her a piggy back all the way
down
another eyewitness i saw a couple of
people jumping out of the other building
i've seen two or three people jump out
of the building
the first one
i don't know if that's number one tower
in the two tower
it's unreal
we got to the plaza area
and there were police and firemen and
medics running everywhere
they came up they took her away
all the shops had been closed but there
was glass everywhere lots of windows had
been smashed
people were sweeping the glass out of
the way so that people could walk out
we were told to go over by the borders
bookstore
we walked up some escalators
by this time a group that was with us
had kind of like fractured and it was
just me and bob
[Music]
we got to the top of the escalators
i walked out to the street
which was absolute chaos
huge bits of building
slang everywhere
you could hear
sirens
and smoke and dusty
awful tracking sounds
and
we looked over
and there was a a krispy kreme there was
a famous krispy kreme shop on the world
trade center plaza
and there was a lady standing there
drinking coffee and eating a doughnut
and like looking
mesmerized looking up at the building
in complete and out of shot
chris we just want to leave it there
just for a moment because we are
receiving some new information here at
sky news center okay
no confirmation at this stage but we
believe there has been a third hijacked
of a jumbo jet
we also believe though again not
confirmed but there are reports of an
explosion at the pentagon i mean you
know bob just
grabbed me and we took off running we
went over to where the policeman was
[Music]
and he said we're evacuating
low manhattan
everyone's going over the brooklyn
bridge so you need to go that way and
there were literally thousands of people
heading across the bridge
and then i said look i lived just across
there i could see my building can i
please go back to my building and he
said
we could uh but looking at that at that
devastation of those two buildings david
i mean the loss of life is going to be
immense isn't it
he turned and started walking against
all the people
and at that point i looked up at the
world trade
and where our floor should have been
there was a gaping hole i i'm just not
believing what i'm seeing at the moment
and i think many people out there who
are watching this feel exactly the same
way i just sat there and cried and i
looked up and i said what's happened
what's happening
he said come on we need to get you back
to the apartment
and i said what's the time
the one point really that i know what
the time was
and it was 9 42 washington and new york
have been hit
by terrorists within the last hour
[Music]
my apartment was on the 17th floor
it was a corner apartment and one side
of the building looked out to the world
trade center and the other side looked
out to the statue of liberty
you look out of one window
and it's chaos of mayhem you look over
the statue of liberty on a beautiful
blue sky day
didn't seem possible that the two sides
of the building could be so different
really
david leah mount is on the line for us
now bob lived in new jersey
the ferries were still going
he said he was going to try and
go home you know
do i want to go with him and i said no
no i'd like to stay here
so he tried to ring his wife a couple of
times and the lines were just
you could get a darling tone you could
ring and then there was just
the lines just went dead so after about
20 minutes he left
i have fears for how that structure is
going to stay together i don't think
we've seen it all yet
the phone rang
which astounded me but you were anxious
about the structure as it was a company
apartment one of the directors was a guy
called kevin and his wife was ringing to
say look we haven't heard from kevin
he might decide to make his way to the
apartment if you can't get out of the
city so you know i just if if he gets
there please obviously call us
[Music]
okay the person calling for help listen
to me you need to calm down and relax i
called london again and i was speaking
to robin
and as i was speaking to him that's when
the first tower fell
the tv flickered
and there was some dust and debris in
the air
and what appears to be a complete
collapse surrounding the entire area
crossing to the world trade center in
new york just a moment or two ago
we saw
the
twin tower it's some 110 stories high
it's starting
to fall apart
there's no other way of expressing
what's happening as you can see these
pictures and there was suddenly this
probably about 10 minutes later now
this
rumbling sound
like hell was opening up
banging crashing kind of bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang
[Applause]
[Music]
and then suddenly this
cloud of
[Music]
the only way that i can really describe
it was if there was someone on
the
rooftop
unrolling some carpet or something
because this billowing cloud started to
roll around the windows
until eventually
the whole
apartment was done
the crockery was rattling in the
dishwasher the windows were vibrating
and humming
and i sat on the sofa
pulled my knees up to me
and just rocked backwards and forwards
and this is it i'm going to die
i'm by myself
and i'm going to die
the darkness i couldn't see
my hand in front of my face and i was
waiting for the building to fall
just to be able to breathe i'm on a pay
phone on the street right now and i
literally cannot see more than a quarter
block away that's how thick the smoke is
but then the humming stopped
the lights flickered on and off
the black outside went to gray
and suddenly
started
disappearing
[Music]
and it was bright blue skies chaos from
uh coast to coast across the united
states we also now can confirm that the
white house has been evacuated the
neighboring treasury building i went and
looked on the other side of
the sears tower in chicago another huge
landmark
in another 10 minutes of phone ring
again it was eileen
[Applause]
that
i would leave
and make my way to her in queens
[Music]
i had my i had a bag strapped across me
i had a little radios i could hear what
was happening john the president left
sarasota florida air force one took off
just a short while ago mr bush returning
to washington i was holding my radio and
i had my candle
in a little dish
and i
went out
open the fire escape
and
hello hello
just echoing
it was full of dust and bits of
cardboard and some kind of i guess
drywall it wasn't wood it was like
drywall kind of stuff and again it was
total blackness but i had my candle so i
was okay
and i started walking down slowly slowly
slowly i was on the 17th floor and again
two staircases for each floor it seemed
much harder walking down those 17 than
it did the 84 from
the world trade center
i got down to the end
on the ground floor
i tried to open the door and there was
so much debris in front of it pieces of
wood and some glass dust i was kicking
it out of the way but i knew that i had
to literally get down on my hands and
knees
so i turned around with a candle to put
it down
and as i turn around it blew out
and it was pitch black
and i didn't have bob with me this time
i don't know where the strength comes
from
but i was on my hands and he's pushing
this stuff out of the way and literally
i could eventually open the door enough
for me to squeeze out
the radio was still
was still working so i could kind of
hear the reporter talking about the
trains not working
as i walked out into the atrium of the
building all the windows were smashed it
was such bright light
no one around us shouted out again hello
hello
no one replied
i walked to the front of the building
opened the doors
and waded out into knee high
debris
i looked across the road
there were cars all just puddled on top
of each other the blue sky
silent so quiet
new york is never quiet
and i shouted out again oh oh
nobody answered me
extraordinary pictures one of the
great monuments to 20th century america
recognizable around the world everybody
who's been to new york city who's been
to manhattan island
couldn't have mistaken those two
towers that i started walking away from
the world trade center and really not
knowing where i was going but knew that
i would hook up with the brooklyn bridge
at sound stage
i bumped into
um some firemen who asked me if i was
okay where was i going and i said i had
to get to queens i said you know where
do i get a train so they said to me you
need to
just just head that way you need to go
to canal street the trains are running
from canal street
so i started walking not seeing very
many people
reports are that there will be quite a
considerable number of casualties it
doesn't bear thinking about exactly what
the numbers are keith graves are u.s
correspondents and then suddenly out of
nowhere i heard this booming voice come
on everyone this way
and i looked across and it was a man
at the top of this crowd of about six
people
and i went running over to them
and i said
i'm i'm looking for canal street station
yep we're going this way come on come
along
got to the station
um somehow
i had a ticket in my hand somehow i was
through the barrier and somehow i was on
a train
[Music]
i then showed him my scrappy piece of
paper with all the train lines i had to
get to get to queens
right he said right you need to go on
this line
and the man came from behind me and said
i know where she's going i'll take her
took me to the right
line
the train came in
he spoke to the conductor
the guy told him where i was going he
said leave it to me
and the guy disappeared
when we got off at rego park
there was uh an mta lady waiting for me
and i said look i need to call my friend
to tell her i'm here but she's gonna
come down and meet me
we went to a little
telephone box on the street
i was scrambling around trying to find
my money she had money
she died and not before me she put money
in the phone she gave me the phone
eileen answered so i was telling her
where i was
and when i looked around the mta lady
had gone
all of these people
in a queue to help me
it was amazing
president bush is not in the capital
he's promised a full scale investigation
though to hump down and find those folks
who put it who committed this act
terrorism again i remember going up to
her apartment
watching up on television casualties are
expected to run into many many thousands
of people you could see the smoke from
the towers
from her balcony
where the towers should have been
and
we had pizza delivered i remember
finding that quite strange
that someone delivered pizza
but we sat on a pizza watch television
but uh there have been many security
alerts from american citizens around the
world in the past few months and the
target of those
alerts is said to come from osama bin
laden um certainly her telephone line
was fine so i called london again i
called
to my mum and dad to let them know that
i was safe
i remember having a shower very
prominent building i mean just
dust
when i stepped down looked at myself in
the mirror
and i knew my life was never gonna be
the same
[Music]
i woke exhausted
but it was agreed that we would set our
pure brokers would set up a help desk
at michael's office midtown manhattan
and i remember the list
of the people that were still missing
it started at 80 and overnight come down
to 60 as people were accounted for
people turning up i mean it took bob a
couple of hours to get home
um
i looked down the list
and kevin
was on the list
and i remembered my heartbreaking calls
with sylvia
dan
dominic steve and jose
the last five people
i saw on the floor four of them were
missing
so that you were brokers
list ended up at sixty people
[Music]
i don't consider myself a strong person
by any means
and when i think back now
i wonder how it did it
but even after all these years
i can close my eyes
and be back there an instant
science the sounds and the smell love
the smell
you find out a lot of stuff afterwards
and the awful tweaking sounds
i could make sense of what when we first
came out
of the world trade center
on the plaza
that was
people were jumping from the buildings
and that's a sound that's with me
forever
20 years later
i can't believe the time's gone so
quickly
and i think that
a long time i couldn't control my
emotions
and being english it's hard right
[Music]
but now after all these years
i know that
if i'm heading that way
i can double up myself
[Music]
it's amazing that the amount of times
i'll look at a clock
and it's at night it says 9 11.
and things that you see
will always remind you
of the people look lost
but i think that
in closing
[Music]
the one thing
that kept me going
the hope that tomorrow will be better
day
[Music]
and you know what
mainly it is
so i hope that you have
learned something
in what i've said today
[Music]
but i think what i hope most of all
is that
sometime today or tomorrow
[Music]
will you give
some thought maybe
to not only all my friends
but to everyone who died on september
11th
and if i can be really indulgent
can i please ask that to you
spare a thought for all the survivors
because we're still struggling
thank you
[Music]
of the four planes hijacked on september
the 11th flight 93 crashed in
pennsylvania with no survivors after
passengers tried to retake the aircraft
janice brooks lives in the uk she
continues to work in finance and
volunteers for the charity since 911 an
education program directed at uk
students
after the 9 11 attacks the u.s
administration under president george w
bush began targeting islamic terror
groups and nations deemed to be
providing support and sanctuary
this war on terror brought about the u.s
led invasion of afghanistan in october
2001 then controlled by the taliban and
being used as a base for al-qaeda and
osama bin laden the mastermind behind
the 911 attacks
911 janice brooks inside the south tower
was produced by rob mulhern
story originator was tom gillespie for
more information go to skynews.com
storycast21
next time less than two years after
watching the events of 9 11 a former
fast food worker turned u.s marine finds
himself tasked with toppling saddam
hussein
i understood
this was a huge deal
it was the end of a regime it was a
turning point in
the timeline in the history of these
people's lives and of their country
[Music]
you